hey everybody I'm gonna keep this intro
really really briefing leap right into
it this is this month's discussion on
lgbtq+ topics and representation and I
have brought on special guests and
Middleton to talk about non-binary
representation I say talk about really
I'm just giving them a platform and then
getting out of the way so let's go em
first of all thank you very much for
joining me my pleasure now I do do I
have the the honor of this being your
video debut yeah yes I stopped I've been
telling my roommate for years that she
can't just start like recording me and
putting me on the internet because I
have a face made for radio and then she
found out that I was doing this
yesterday and so as soon as she found
out she was like oh so your face has
already been on YouTube and I'm like oh
I feel like this is some sort of
horrible Pandora's box that I've opened
up for myself yeah we are gonna have a
conversation or we're gonna try to about
non-binary representation
I'm really excited about this cuz you
pitched this video to me like months ago
and because our schedules are both sort
of insane it's taken a while for us to
get together and talk so I've just been
slowly making notes and I was kind of
pleasantly surprised by the state of
non-binary representation especially for
the last couple of years
there were some promising things I found
but before we get into any specific
representations let's I want to make
sure that anybody watching is
understands the terminology and what it
is we're actually talking about so how
would you explain to someone your gender
identity as non-binary so I would say
that for me personally what it means
being on binary is a sort of a lack of
restrictions on the types of words that
I am allowed to use for myself and the
freedom from sort of correlations that
because I might feel or present a
certain way does not necessarily entail
all of the other baggage that might come
with it that I am able to take on
certain like certain aspects of
femininity but that does not then equal
must be woman must be straight etc etc
etc all of which are untrue or because
is masculine must have certain interests
must behave certain way must accent way
must sound certain way so it's sort of
breaking those those sort of
correlations that we have about well if
you are like X you must also be like ABC
and it's like now those are those are
actually all separate things that don't
have to exist in a person simultaneously
just because of their gender or their
biological sex or the the name or gender
they were given at their birth it's all
it's all about breaking boundaries
breaking binaries yes tearing down the
walls it's looking at the categories and
saying no actually this is the perfect
explanation one of my fellow non-binary
friends did a Twitter poll a couple of
weeks ago and said do I strike you as
boy girl no so some people would say
both and people like myself would say no
when it came to mind trying to find
instances of non-binary representation
and part of the reason I had to do
research and
even take notes which is that's huge for
me is because the instances that I found
not a single one was in anything I've
ever seen
yes so there's there's a decent amount
of non binary representation if you
either a sort of expand your definition
a little bit or look at really really
really fringe very new things yeah I'm
going to get a lot of your
representation as as people have been
more visible and have talked more about
being non-binary and what it means to be
non-binary and how one experience is
being non-binary the media has gotten
better but it also means if you're
trying to find really good canonical non
binary representation that can be kind
of difficult not because it's not there
but because it's kind of muddy let me
ask you this prior to doing research for
this and like going out of your way to
find out what was out there
have there been a character in any
medium be it comic books or novels or TV
or movies or whatever that even if they
were not necessarily written to be
non-binary that spoke to you it sort of
connected in that way so yes there are a
couple of these are actually canonical
but again they're from like pretty
recent the last like two or three years
I think a lot of people like myself who
grew up in the early 90s and did not
identify as female and we're sort of
trying to figure out what that meant
about ourselves I think a lot of us had
our first sort of queer awakening
reading the song of the lioness the
Elana quartet written by tamara pierce i
think that that was just a really
formative experience i think for a lot
of young people young women young queer
people and young non-binary and trans
people but i think that at least for
myself it got pretty disheartening
the later the books went on the more you
started to realize oh this is this
character who I thought might be not me
like might be like me
super isn't super duper isn't she really
really really is into guys and she
really wants to wear dresses and the
fact that she can't do it just hurts her
so much and it's like okay that was nice
while it lasted I think a lot of people
also felt that way about mulan although
with with less of the betrayal that was
Disney I don't think anyone necessarily
had the expectation there no and and in
that case it was very much you're like
oh this is a person who I can kind of
sort of squint and be like there there's
something there there's something in
like reflections that just like really
gets to me and I just can't figure out
why because I'm 11 and being raised in a
heteronormative cisgendered society and
I don't understand how to process the
emotions that I'm having from this which
are apparently very different from
everyone else who's watching it well
it's funny when you when you think back
at the stuff that you gravitated to as a
kid do you start connecting like oh my
god like wow I wonder how I missed this
and then you just have to remind
yourself it's it's the Syst normativity
that's what it that's what it was yeah
yeah pretty much
the big one right now is the character
of Taylor Mason on the show billions
this is I think it's on Showtime they're
making the claim of not the first
non-binary character but they're making
the claim of the first regularly
appearing non-binary character in a
mainstream US television show which I
think they might be able to claim this
is also completely outside my world to
you so it's like a like I've never seen
it but it's like a like a financial
thriller kind of show it's like a it's
like a a skeevy banker trying to out
smart basically the Federal Trade
Commission and something to that effect
okay but also the character is played by
a non-binary actor that's Asia Kate
Dylan who apparently had their breakout
role on oranges the new black which just
gives me one more reason that I wish I
liked that show because I can't stand it
but it has Ruby Rose in it it has Ruby
Rose and it has Asian King : and it was
the breakout for um oh my god now I've
forgotten her name Cox thank you a
moment of like queer panic it was the
launching pad for all these people and
I'll appreciate it for that but I just
didn't like the show well part of what I
found interesting was that most of
certainly the more recent non-binary
characters that I could find were
actually being played by if not 9 bit
and if not non-binary at least trans
people or people who were not cisgender
so and I have to wonder if part of that
is is it because like the understanding
of non-binary as even being a thing is
it at least in the mainstream is so
relatively recent if that just happens
to coincide with the point in time where
you know people like you know
homosexuals and lesbians and trans
people are saying we need to be playing
ourselves that that is far enough along
that at the time non-binary characters
are even kind of happening that push has
already happened and so the same so it's
happening right off the bat for that I
have to wonder I think probably
especially for character like for at
least in the case of in John wick 3 they
said that the the character was not
originally intended to be non-binary but
when a non-binary actor came in and said
hi I would like to you know read for
this role and they were like they're
fantastic they're incredible they're
amazing that then sort of the next
thought was well hang on a second why
does this character have to be female
awesome which is awesome so that is one
of those cases of actually making a
character non-binary after the fact in
order to have because you're like well
now we have this this chance to have a
non-binary actor portraying themselves
in a certain way which i think is like
awesome and and is almost sort of what
we should aspire to and in a certain
sense I'm not like completely bothered
by the concept of sis people playing
non-binary characters but it is nice to
have non-binary or the very least queer
people telling these stories like I
think because I I have it I'm on the
record as having some very serious
issues with cisgender people playing
transgender characters but it is worth
making a distinction I think at least on
some level because a since non-binary
representation is fairly recent it
doesn't have the historical baggage that
screwed up trans representation does in
the first place and the implications of
having a cisgender actor aren't quite as
gross because part of the problem with
having a sis actor play a trans
character is is it reinforces the idea
of oh well they are the
really still the gender they were
assigned at birth because you're casting
someone and they pretty much always cast
someone who is the same gender as the
character was assigned at Birth yeah and
most egregious with trans women because
this is a long history of trans women
are just desperate gay men and there's
just a long history of transphobia and
homophobia and all sorts of stuff that
goes into that which non-binary people
by sort of like sliding under the radar
have sort of managed to mostly avoid
most mostly people think that we're just
lesbians which is also not accurate
except the lesbians say that non-binary
lesbians can't exist which is also
incorrect in fighting that's always I
love my fellow LGBTQ people like my
family with with all the implications
that that term has so another one that I
found that was from something that I
recognized there's a character on the
anime attack on Titan call I don't know
if I'm gonna pronounce this right cuz I
did three episodes of attack on Titan
and realized it wasn't for me the
character is Zoe hang I believe they're
uh they're a squad leader and I don't
know what it's like on the anime but in
the original trans English translation
of the manga it was translated with
she/her pronouns the creator of the
original manga see ever I can not
butcher this Hajime isayama actually
requested that they remove references to
any specific gender which which not only
did they do for all of the volumes that
hadn't been released yet on reprints of
the ones they had released they also
fixed that nice I I also have some
pretty serious problems with attack on
Titan and like with you it's super not
for me but I do really appreciate that
props to the creator for actually saying
no please stop misgendering this
character we have a singular like
non-gendered pronoun in Japanese and I
would appreciate it if you actually use
the correct pronouns are the best
equivalent that you have in English so
kudos everyone involved on that actually
that's interesting I didn't realize that
they had a gender-neutral singular and
in Japanese were crazy because they have
like 17 pronouns which is like both
awesome and kind of horrifying so I mean
I've been throwing out a few what were
what were something that you had come
across so I started broke mine down into
two chunks that there are the sort of
ambiguous up to interpretation kind of
more headcanon yeah which I definitely
wanted to start with mostly because I
wanted to talk about my wife Brienne of
Tarth I dodge Game of Thrones sucked me
in for two episodes and I'm pretty sure
you know what to I'm talking about and
then they then they kicked me out me
personally I'm not allowed back in
because they ruined everything that I
loved two things Brienne of Tarth
deserves happiness and Brienne of Tarth
deserves respect
yes facts and if she does not get the
ending that she has definitely earned
I'm gonna personally find george RR
martin and half words here's what i'm
gonna recommend read the book and hope
that the book doesn't better than the
show did yeah I've I've been keeping
vaguely involved with the books because
I have one friend who watches the show
and keeps me updated mostly about things
involving Brienne and I have a friend
who's reading the books or has read the
books and keeps me updated about Brienne
so I mean the book trajectory is going
better so I'm better than me then maybe
the landing will be better too because
the the show
not-not-not so much but i wanted to talk
about her a little bit because there
have been I have heard some implications
that brand is not entirely identify as
female and this is the thing that I
wanted to talk about because it's a
really common trope in non binary
representation and I wanted to sort of
address it a little bit sure because
this falls into the allot of the mulan's
things like that that a lot of
non-binary stories or stories that can
be read as being about non-binary people
often involve this like really strong
rejection of femininity hmm
which is a little bit troubling for a
couple of reasons because on the one
hand it sort of reinforces the
assumption that in order to be
non-binary you must reject gender norms
entirely like you're not allowed to have
them you're not allowed to keep anything
from whatever like gender you were
assigned at Birth which can be really
damaging to a lot of I mean even just
even to binary trans people who are like
yes I am a man I have transitioned I use
him pronouns but I like to bake and all
of a sudden people are like well that's
cause you're still secretly girly on the
inside like it also reinforces that the
only way to be non-binary is to be a Dra
Janice they need to be this like vaguely
masculine ish you know sort of like
genderless creature in order to be
non-binary which can also be somewhat
somewhat damaging I mean like that's
some people's Jam obviously but that
with the minute you start saying this is
the only way to to be something BAE
that's usually something that has as
broad of like an umbrella as non-binary
like you're everyone who does not
identify as male or female or both male
and female like everybody else is
allowed to just chill then placing
restrictions on what a non-binary person
is that like all nine all non-binary
people
our assigned female at birth untrue and
hate being women maybe like a little I
think that's just such a reductive way
of understanding things so I definitely
wanted to give this a shout-out because
I loved Brianna's a character and she
sort of sort of typifies like the best
option of this sort of representation
also I just I just I just love her I
love her and I mostly wanted to make the
joke that her gender is night sir sirs
and her sexual orientation is justice so
what actually what's interesting when
you talk about like the rejection of
femininity I think there's like a little
tweak of it with Brienne like versus
something like Mulan or you know
something where it's a more active
rejection either because they don't want
it or because it it's something that's
not safe for them under the
circumstances that they're in the sets I
get from Brienne if she has any
rejection of her feminity femininity
it's because those things wouldn't help
her do what she wants to do exactly so
it's not it's not a hatred of femininity
is just well that doesn't help me be a
better night so no that can stay behind
exactly and and that's why I think that
she's uh she that she is is sort of a
cut above the archetypical girl pretends
to be boy in order for whatever story
which unfortunately is what we had for
like decades so I would say centuries
because you can go to shows there's a
there was a reason will be called
upgrade that has a character named Jamie
who's a hacker and requests that their
gender not be asked for and makes it
clear that Jamie is a chosen name not a
birth one and again that is a case where
the actor Kay Bradley is non-binary so
that had that again which was cool and
then like I found a number of things
that were interesting but like this is
stuff nobody will have heard of so like
there was a web there was a vampire web
series called Carmela oh you what are
you talking about I had never heard of
it before I looked this up that's where
I learned the concept of log non-binary
lesbians
well I'm terminal is great okay well
there you go cuz because they've got
they've got two one there I believe
they've got Fontaine and they've got
Caitlyn who are you who are both
non-binary and I believe I believe the
actors are as well or at the very least
for LaFontaine is the other one I wasn't
like the other one I couldn't confirm
just because they don't like have a
social media presence like there are
more private person yeah so it's like
but but yeah that was when I hadn't
heard of before I mean this this is a
name I recognise but like I wasn't ever
gonna watch this so apparently in
Degrassi next class okay there's an
there's a non-binary character in that
now that character is played by a sis
female actress but was actually as I
said one of the very few instances where
I found of uh sis actor playing a
non-binary so I'm actually not even
gonna like hold it against them so much
because it's not yeah it's not like oh
god this friggin trend because like it's
not a trend the trend is actually the
correct way to do it so yeah apparently
there was a crowdfunded show in Canada
called the switch which like had a
complete cache and creators awesome and
actually was the only instance that I
could find in a piece of entertainment
of using pronouns other than they them I
believe they had a character that used
Z's er for their pronouns which boy I
wonder how many people's minds we just
slew that like yes there are there are a
number of none of them
caught on yeah but there are a number of
because it's both the most common but
also functions as an umbrella yeah in a
situation where you're like I'm pretty
sure that you don't use he or she but
we're in a situation where I don't
necessarily feel comfortable asking so
they is usually a safe guess and it's
generally accepted it's like yeah you
can go with that but there are it's sort
of like referring to people as
non-binary in general but non-binary for
some people like myself that's like my
specific chosen like preferred identity
and nomenclature but there are other
people who are like you can call me
non-binary but I'd rather more say
gender fluid I think that's a little
more accurate or a gender I think that's
more accurate
so both non-binary and they can function
in the specific or in the general yeah
well and I think part of the reason that
it goes today as well as like it's also
word people already know it's a slightly
different usage but it's not literally
having to learn a whole new words as
with ads with some of the singular
gender neutrals that have tried to get
going in English and as I said none of
them have really stuck now so you
brought up you know the people who are
kind of for lack of a better term like
non-specified and the headcanon which I
figured there was going to be a bit of
because I ran into this one I had the
conversation about asexuality which was
oftentimes
you have the the people who need that
representation latch on to anyone who
just isn't specified and that happens
with asexual quote unquote
representation of law absolutely where
people will just headcanon someone who
doesn't have a romantic pairing at all
like oh maybe that one please please
please please
and with non-binary you get that a
little bit and actually oddly where you
find that a surprising amount I found is
in video games
there's a fair number of characters who
either because it doesn't come up or
it's not important and then the way that
they are visually designed you just
don't know
including one lead character I've never
played undertale I'm so sorry I forgot
about the lead from undertale I don't
remember what your name is but yeah risk
yes is never specified as being either
male or female and the sprite
you can't tell yep just a kid which
again is not to say that the character
is necessarily specifically intended to
be non-binary but it does allow you
freedom to basic it it's it's the ideal
sort of player avatars like re are you
male are you female you can see them
that way are you neither you can see
them that way and it's it's a it's a
good use of the medium and the kind of
things that video games can do that
other things can't yes honestly I did
want to give one shout out still to the
Dragon Age series which is that in the
Dragon Age series in the character
creator there are some non binary
options that while you do still pick
male or female to be your base character
and that will give you your build
options for like the musculature like
their physicality and also their voice
options if you pick a female avatar you
can still give her an Adam's apple
if you pick a female avatar you can give
her facial hair so there are there are
some things that video games are slowly
starting to add into those customizable
characters and of course there's Sims 4
which just blew all of the boxes out of
the water like if you're making a
character everything is selectable there
are no correlations there is no you're
gonna pick a male body which means that
this person will not have you know
defined breasts this person like will
have you know masculine like appearances
or bodies no all of that stuff is
customizable just because you pick a
male voice does not mean you're gonna
get any sort of requirements on whether
or not that character can become
pregnant
so that is that is a cool thing and I
want to I want to give a shout out to
the sims 4 for making essentially every
randomly generated NPC in sims like any
character that you make just by hitting
random they're almost certainly going to
be non-binary because they don't they
don't pick the gender for you and start
they'll just go through and randomly
select traits that I actually hadn't
heard about that one that is very cool
and actually given how big the sims is
I'm kind of surprised that that didn't
waft back at me at any point yeah it was
it was a pretty it was a pretty big deal
and there were some people who were big
bad about it oh I'm sure there were and
there was this is off the time I had
this didn't come up in my research so I
may be misremembering this so if I if I
get it wrong someone will correct me I'm
in the comments I'm sure cuz they always
do so I think it was the Saints Row
series now they didn't keep this but I
think it was in the second game cuz you
got to customize your protagonist in
those and in the second game they had
gender as a slider bar oh nice umm but
but then when they got to the third one
they made they they went back to having
you yeah hard hard pick one or the other
another thing I came across and I want
to get your opinion on this what is your
feeling about the instances of
characters who are non-binary but also
aren't human so this is the other big
thing this is V I would say the single
most common canonical non-binary trope
everything else is and you know sort of
tropes about assumptions that people
have or like is this character
non-binary maybe maybe not what's the
like evidence for that yeah this is the
one of just the the absolute most common
and probably also most frustrating
stereotype is this character is
not of a binary gender excellent because
they're an inhuman robot or an alien or
lack of physical form of any variety and
here's the thing a lot of those
characters are awesome I have one of
them on my like canonical recent like
current non-binary characters list um
Janet from the good place is amazing
oh she's I love her so much like she's
great
Jadzia Dax for example would be a
non-binary character because Jadzia's
like gender is a thing that changes over
time her species does not have the same
concept of maleness and femaleness being
tied to your biology so a way that we do
they still have gender expectations but
in a different way the problem with all
of that is that having a person with a
gender that they insist frequently they
either do not have a gender or their
gender is different or they want people
to stop assuming their gender is because
they're not human and it's a thing that
sets them apart from the other
characters in a kind of backhanded way
I'm saying well of course Janet doesn't
have a gender because she's a concept
yes she she so frequently reiterates you
know not a girly girl but not bad yeah
not not a girl because also not a human
so not really prepared to be defined by
the human terms in the first place like
any of them yeah and I I have fingers
crossed for the good place because the
people writing that show are both very
smart and very empathetic so my hopes is
that as the show goes on that a lot of
Janet's character arc has been
connecting more to humanity and becoming
more human becoming more than what she
has been in the past so if she gains
more humanity
becomes more of a person and and stops
insisting that she's not a person but
still insists that she's not a girl that
would be awesome that's what that's what
that's what we're aiming for so I'm very
hopeful that they're going to go in that
direction that they're gonna sort of
recognize some of the troubling
implications that this type of
representation has and grow from it and
allow her as a character to grow so I'm
hopeful I'm hopeful about Janet there is
a book called this one is actually a
closed in common orbit but it is in the
Wayfarers series by Becky chambers the
first book of that was the long way to a
small angry planet and it is a I highly
recommended very very good it is a book
that is very derogative Lee referred to
as a soft science fiction but as a
person who got a degree in a soft
science I'm actually very I'm very
excited about it because it's actually
very accurate that it takes soft science
concepts of gender theory and sociology
and political theory and apply economics
things like that and applies them in the
same way that physics would be applied
in a science fiction story huh so
there's a lot of very intense world
building specifically that has to do
with social norms and rules and
societies and how people interact so in
that series
zere is the agreed on like basic
gender-neutral pronoun because aliens
exist in that society and a lot of
aliens use he and she because they have
sexual dimorphism some aliens do not and
as a result either their gender changes
over time or they have not just more
than two genders they actually have more
than two sexes so one of the species
what like the major alien species that
exists in this world are the aliens
who are a sort of like fish-like species
okay and so as a couple things about
them they do not speak and they can
they're all deaf they communicate
entirely through color oh god it's so
cool so like just like so like the way
that their society functions is very
alien because they never had spoken
language until they made contact with
aliens and when they made contact with
aliens
they got technology they use to like
augment themselves so that they can
actually communicate so they have like
translators so that they can hear other
people and so that they can
quote-unquote speak and a thing that's
very cool about them is that they
actually have four sexes because they're
an egg-laying species so they have those
that produce eggs those that fertilize
eggs those that are infertile and have
neither so that would be okay that's
your third that's your a non-binary and
those that move between them so this is
this is a reflection of like real world
things like with clownfish where they
can like change sexes depending on like
the the social or not the social factors
but the environmental factors on the
school and in this world those factors
aren't environmental their social
Angela's our degree biological and so
there is a character by the name of tak
tak who is one of these fourth gender
individuals and it means that
zere will go from masculine to neutral
to feminine to neutral to masculine and
back and forth and back and forth
throughout the course of the book on
like a pretty regular cycle so you have
one character who is referred to by
three different sets of pronouns based
on the time of year that it is and
there's some there's some like really
cool stuff that goes on with gender in
that book with alien
because the way that they present
themselves is the way that you refer to
them end of story
so if one of these fourth gender persons
is like physically presenting as being
masculine you use he him you do not use
ZZ er you don't you don't include any
sort of ambiguity ambiguity in that
situation because like nope I'm male
right now and you will address me as
such and in nine months I will probably
be female and you will address me as
such so that was like a cool thing
because in their culture there are
people who use zir flap that's it and
they're like that's not my gender hmm so
it's like it like takes non-binary and
to a certain degree sort of sort of
breaks down like there are people who
have binary genders then there are
non-binary people and then there are
gender fluid people like at a biological
level which is like kind of really cool
I I would say that's really cool but
that is a very common thing a lot of the
characters who I found who were either
gender fluid or non-binary like just not
sis and not binary trans like the two
things that I think our society has sort
of come to like except like okay so
there's this people and there's binary
trans people and even if we don't like
those trans people we get them yeah
I think our society in America
definitely has a long way to go before
it recognizes that there's more options
than that one the thing is non-binary or
gender fluid or or anything of that or a
gender or anything of that nature is
fundamentally more disruptive to the
what had been the societal understanding
of gender than transgender is
transgender was still disruptive but it
was still going between the known sides
of the spectrum yeah
so to say that well no your entire
foundation is wrong we got to blow all
this up that's much more threatening for
lack of a better term yes um do you want
me to get socio-political here on your
gun a little bit go for it okay so hello
everyone welcome to gender 101 if you
didn't know that binary trans people
have always existed throughout all of
history they have if you did not know
that non-binary people have also existed
through all of history welcome to class
because there are a wide variety of
societies who have had more than two
genders here on earth with living human
people for centuries and in some cases
millennia not to get too far out into
the weeds but a lot of this comes back
to colonialism because when Western
persons encountered people from say
Mexico who would say that they are mushi
seems like what does that mean mu XE
it's like mujer but masculine so you're
a masculine lady yes I don't get that
and I don't like that there's a long
history of people from a variety of
societies where those societies have had
three four five six seven eight etc
genders and the interesting thing about
a lot of these like social groups is
that they could be filled by intersex
people non-binary people binary trans
people people that today we would still
probably consider sis but within their
own society people recognized no there's
something else
something that we probably don't even
have a word for so I just think that
that is super cool super awesome and a
thing that I can sort of cling to that
even though right now in America we have
very strict assumptions about gender
identity and even though the history of
trans people and of non-binary people is
so sort of sequestered away in these
tiny little pockets that have survived
it still does exist we do still have a
history that goes back millennia that
goes back to India and Africa and the
Middle East and Mexico and Albania
Albania has one of the coolest like
gender concepts that I've ever come
across which was the concept of a sworn
virgin which we would essentially
probably consider to be trans men okay
but they very specifically exists
outside of masculinity and femininity
and even even though these people dress
in a masculine fashion are usually
referred to as like in male contexts and
with male terms if asked they will say
like no we're not men we're something
else and they exist in this sort of this
this neither sphere and it's a thing
that's as these sections of rural
Albania has become more cosmopolitan is
actually sort of fading away let's see
the 15a of Polynesia who are the third
neither masculine or feminine persons
there is the entirety of the the
two-spirit identity which has been
largely reclaimed by a lot of indigenous
American people who we would consider
baby queer trans non-binary but they
have their own
their own language that they have sort
of retained for themselves and are very
very proud of and I'm I'm just like so
stoked that like their own history has
been preserved like within their own
community it's awesome let's see ooh
here's one that I found about Vedic
India which I like for more
philosophical reasons that in India in
the like 4th and 5th century CE II a lot
of things that had to do with natural
philosophy so early sciences talk about
the three natural genders and that the
three natural genders extended to
everything that the universe was made of
masculine feminine and neuter energy
that animals existed in feminine
masculine and neuter situations that
plants could be feminine masculine or
neuter and that people were also Pham
feminine masculine or neuter that is
very cool so it's not so it's not only
not only is being non-binary within this
like concept of existence not only is it
not disruptive it is the definition of
balance that Trant like that trans and
non-binary and intersex people are
essential to the balance of the cosmos
not to be totally narcissistic but I
really like the idea that like we're the
ones holding it all together like a
level like we're the ones who keep like
the universe on balance I don't know how
much like personal talk we're gonna get
into later but like that was my
coming-out because I took a gender 101
sociology class and my super-awesome
like 65 year old Jewish professor was
like hey guys did you know that a lot of
societies there are three genders not
two when I went it was like the base
basically the best day of my life so
anytime I can I can talk about the
albanians worn virgins I probably will
so like the the last couple that I've
got are a couple of samples that I
pulled for for problematic
so I don't want to dive into that right
off so I'll I'll kind of just hand over
the reins and whatever sort of things we
haven't already brought up that because
I know you I know you have lots and lots
of notes so can I have so many I have so
many notes um I'm gonna go back into
some of my ambiguous characters then
because you're gonna talk about
problematic stuff I want to talk about
anime anime and Japanese culture in
general has a long transphobic history
so one of my sort of maybe canonical
characters is the character of Crona
from the anime Soul Eater which I love
and I love Crona like I think that
they're like a really interesting very
tragic like super cool character in this
particular instance crona's lack of a
distinct gender identity is a result of
abuse which is not great yeah as like a
one-to-one but it is a valid character
choice in this context and I think is a
very interesting thing to bring up like
I said with the attack on Titan
character Japanese has a singular gender
neutral pronoun and that is the one that
even when Crona originally an antagonist
becomes one of the protagonists and one
of the supporting characters continues
to use the the singular pronoun lists
the singular gender-neutral and everyone
else is very sort of confused about this
because they're like well you've gotten
out of this like terrible situation
wouldn't you kind of want to actually
start presenting as whatever your true
gender is and they say no I don't have
any desire to do that actually
I'm kind of okay with how I am now and
I'm like just sort of starting to work
on my like trauma so I'm not really
interested in picking a new gender at
the moment and everyone else is sort of
like okay weird but cool in the English
dub they gave corona male pronouns ah
yeah why because because obviously this
is a case of a boy being forced to act
in some way feminine as a form of abuse
and I'm like oh great great great you
know what I just realized is there's a
potential non-binary character in my
favorite anime show and for some reason
that didn't pay my radar it's it's not
as widely known as I would like but
escaflowne is I so need to watch that
like I literally don't know anything
about if I don't know it's very good god
is my favorite anime and there is a
villain character I can't I haven't
rewatched it in ages so I cannot
remember I think that they use masculine
pronouns to refer to him but it's but
the original Japanese I don't remember
what they did with the English dub
because the English this this was dubbed
over in like the late 90s early 2000s
when the dubs were still terrible so
it's don't worry it's what it's one of
the few that I I watched was because
normally I prefer dubs to subtitles but
I watched this one with the subtitles
and in Japanese the character is voiced
by a woman and and has a very you know
is always an armor so like whatever
secondary sex characteristics there are
and you can't tell ya who knows there's
a lot of androgynous villains
yes so that's the thing there's a lot of
androgynous villains or there are a lot
of female characters who are androgynous
because androgyny is considered
attractive so just because a character
is androgynous or dresses androgynous
lead
necessarily mean that they are
non-binary that's a lot of times just a
short camp a shortcut for hey look this
character is hot which also then
coincides in a very weird and
uncomfortable way with sexy woman
villain yeah where there's a lot of
villainesses that are very androgynous
where you go okay so this is there's
some there's some sexism bleeding into
this which is really unfortunate and
unfortunately common there are also a
lot of very campy over-the-top character
designs that will go for villains and
antagonist characters which are actually
really big transphobic like caricatures
of drag queens and the like drag queen
culture is really look down on in Japan
at least it it has been in the past I
think now it's getting a little bit more
acceptance maybe but there is a lot of
transphobia and homophobia that's tied
up in assumptions of men who want to
wear dresses and it can get really super
uncomfortable really quickly which is
why the anime Ouran High School Host
Club really bothers me because there's
so much potential mmm and partially
because of the nature of the show
because it is a melodrama and a satire
it means that a lot of things are
punched up to 11 like for the sake of a
joke like all the characters are an
extreme caricature which unfortunately
means that the main character Haruhi is
is very androgynous in a way that is
intended to be like attractive and is
occasionally played for Laughs in a way
that makes me kind of uncomfortable just
due to the premise of the show because
the general conceit of the show is that
she is pretending to
you be a sexy boy in sexy boy club for
for plot reasons because anime and I
really like Haruhi as a character but
everything is played up as a joke
because everyone assumes that she is a
straight man and she is a straight woman
get it which it's like really
frustrating because there are definitely
moments where I was like you know what
with an updated dub this could be like
one of the best queer animes because
there's a lot of moments in there where
people are talking to Haruhi just as she
is just in her normal everyday life
where she has short hair and she wears
baggy clothes and she basically looks
like me and people are making
assumptions of like oh well you're not
in like boy clubs so like do I need to
like treat you like a lady and she's
like no and then she'll be in boy club
and people will be like oh you're this
incredible gentleman and she's like no
so there's like a lot of there's a lot
of potential there for like having a
character who is actively just entirely
disinterested in gender and who stands
outside of gender and makes fun of all
of these over-the-top social
expectations of like boys have to act
like this and girls have to act like
that and having a main character who
could stand back and be like that's all
ridiculous could be awesome but
unfortunately between the writing that
was put into the anime and then the
translation it's not I mean I watch it I
watched every episode why do we do this
to ourselves
no but the the part that makes me
saddest about Ouran High School Host
Club is because it has the best
canonical queer person in anime not
Harley because the story makes it pretty
clear like event
she's gonna grow her hair out she's
gonna settle down which is another queer
phobic stereotype because high school
girls like to kiss each other and it's
so great and cute but then you grow up
varian's yeah right it's awesome it's
specifically for like queer women and
it's just great it's awesome way to go
so not Haruhi because the story does not
bear that out
but Haru he's dad is the best queer
character in anime like canonical 100%
Haruhi's dad works in an okama bar
essentially a drag bar where it's it's a
gay bar but specifically where the hosts
perform in drag and how he's dad is not
only a professional crossdresser but is
canonically bisexual and is awesome rock
ranca Fujioka has no time for your
anything there's this like running joke
that all anime dads are like the literal
pits like they're all the worst they're
all like yelling at their kids to get in
the Mack because they need to get in the
robot and fight angels but like and like
leaving their children with a bunch of
emotional baggage or like literally
leaving cursed objects in their will and
then like initiating this whole journey
where you need to go deal with your
daddy issues like anime dads are the
worst
except for ranca Fujioka who is the best
who is not only 100% like caring for her
daughter like being like totally
involved emotionally available like
protective but in like a very reasonable
manner even when like crazy weird random
hijinks happen that is that is the like
shot in the dark of like oh you weren't
trying to make a character who is like
realistic and honest and good and
high-quality and and just generally who
I love who's not some sort of crazy
weird stereotype and you did it like oh
my god you did it
how I I suspect that they accidentally
stumbled into awesomeness
absolutely because the absolute worst
part of Ouran High School Host Club is
the way that they decided to translate
the word okama when they go to Harvey's
apartment
and meet her father all of the boys go
oh her dad is a [ __ ]
oh my so if you'll excuse me I'm gonna
go grab a torch in a pitchfork I'm gonna
go hunt down some translators oh my god
because what it should be translated as
is weird even if you want to say that in
like a weird derogatory way like gross
but okay there's a massive difference
because queer can be a pejorative but
it's also been reclaimed by at least a
portion of the community
nobody's reclaiming Trani everyone is
trying to leave behind nobody especially
because as rohnke specifically states
frequently she's not gay she's not
interested in transitioning she will
still occasionally use he/him pronouns
depending on the context she just likes
being pretty and allowing like being
allowed to go about her daily life as
she wishes
oh that just hurts my mellow I know I'm
so frustrating always because like that
could be like the best gay anime like of
all time because like mmm but but nope
nope it's got to be too mired down in
assumptions and stereotypes
for its own good so I just have to sit
here and yeah and try and love it do the
pain
the worst stuff that I came across since
we seem to have backed into that um I've
got good stuff on the other end I've got
like queer stuff by queer poker like I
can say so and thankfully this seems to
not be happening much anymore but it's
you know when non-binary characters show
up in comedies it's pretty much always
as a punchline of some sort so again I
didn't watch this cuz I know it just but
apparently in Zoolander 2 his character
called
all yeah it's it's it's a mockery
now I conceptually I like all but again
if if all was written and performed by a
queer person if if all was performed by
who they should have been performed by
which is justin vivian bond that would
have been amazing the thing I can't get
super ticked off at that because I don't
think it's born out of malice it's born
out of ignorance like they had the idea
and didn't bother to look into it all
they just did it as the idea as they had
it I think I think this is why like this
hetero creators if they're doing a
comedy that involves gay jokes they need
to ask gay people
cuz that's the worst thing about like
gay characters and queer characters and
trans characters and comedy is the
writers don't know what's funny yeah
like there are jokes there are jokes
that can be made ranca Fujioka weirdly
manages to make one of my favorite like
trans jokes ever when the boys show up
at her house and she's like just gotten
home from work like maybe three hours
ago cuz it's like 6 o'clock in the
morning
like she's got it like her little tiny
mustache and like her hair's all down
and she's got bags under her eyes and
she just opens the door he's like I am
sorry sir I have the wrong apartment
and she goes who are you calling sir
just cuz a lady doesn't have her face
like that's amazing that's great like
awesome
that's legitimately and that's about it
like a couple months ago contra points
had a video basically pointing out that
the problem with gay and trans jokes is
they are they are stupid and lazy
because they're being made by people who
don't understand the custom to make fun
of something properly you need to
understand it otherwise you're just
sewing huh that's weird and you know
yeah and then yeah exactly
you're just pointing out of something
and going right right that's not a joke
but speaking of jokes
so the recurring character on Saturday
Night Live known as because regrettably
I suspect that is still some people's
mental image of a non-binary person and
to be fair aside from like a bad fashion
sense the visualization isn't awful but
the entire running joke is oh we can't
tell isn't it so funny that nobody can
tell yeah that's it's that it's that fun
we don't have a joke or really a
character but we can objectify yeah and
that's gonna be funny for people who
aren't you yeah that's a fun one
so having sort of taking us to the
depths of that well you know that just
sort of yank a a phrase from from my
occasional sponsor radio versus the
Martians we've done the bottom of the
barrel let's go to the top of the
mountain what are some of your favorites
okay this is this is where I get to be
really excited so you asked earlier
about a character who sort of was maybe
sort of like a first experience of like
a canonical non-binary character or
something like that and I said Ilana
because to a certain extent that was
true but as it turned out it was a sham
it was a sham and I was tricked
that was not her intention but man did I
feel betrayed the first actual canonical
non-binary character who I encountered
and immediately latched on to was the
shining Knight and this was a character
from the new 52 in DC Comics in like
2010 2011 ish I was in college I've been
out of buying comics for well over a
decade at that point because the last
comic I'd probably bought when I was
like 6 and I was just looking at all of
these new titles that were gonna be
starting and one of them was something
called demon Knights I was like oh well
that's interesting I like fantasy
stories so I guess I'll pick up this
comic it's not gonna be tied into
anything else it won't matter what like
the Batman continuity is or you know
it's not gonna be crossing over a bunch
with crazy things I'll get that and it
was basically d indeed the comic book
huh it's amazing I love it the Golden
Age shining Knight was just a knight
named Justin very very Golden Age very
very nice but Grant Morrison said well
basically let's do an Alana story let's
be like okay so this this case
caracter wanted to be a knight and so
she pretended to be a boy so that she
could be a Lancelot Squire so she could
be near him I'm like okay whatever it's
an interesting series and I quite like
it but the only reason I really like it
is actually because of Paul Cornell's
take on the character in the new 52 in
which Houston is a canonically
non-binary and perhaps intersex
character and this is just like a great
representation or a a great example of
straight sis writers somehow managing to
write like really really good characters
because the question of yes Tain's
gender originally did start off as a
joke to like basically all in sundry
because he rolls up into a tavern and is
like what ho everyone I am the greatest
and strongest and most valiant Knight of
Camelot look at me and all of my great
mighty manly deeds and everyone's like
that's clearly like a 17 year old girl
like that person is like the weightiest
scrawniest little like turd that I've
ever seen in my life but I guess he's a
man sure if you insist and over time the
jokes dropped off and everyone were like
no that's just yes done that's just how
he is he's just like that and at one
point yes 10 is injured and in a very
Mulan asked moment you sort of see you
know his armor has been taken off and
he's laying in the bed and they're like
nuns or priests or whatever who were
sort of like trying to tend to his
injuries and call in one of the other
members of the team like so we need to
have a discussion because I've never
seen this before your companion is okay
but I'm not sure what
[Music]
and that's the end of the discussion so
there is an in big an ambiguity and
people got kind of like gone on Twitter
in interviews have asked Paul Cornell
like so what's up with yes 10 and he
actually had a very classy response
which was I'm not going into details
about this characters genitals like you
don't need to know that makes me so
happy
way to go dude he was like it doesn't
matter what yes 10 would count as in our
modern parlance or how he would consider
himself here in the story he has a man
he has breasts he's attracted to women
and you don't need to know what's in his
pants end of discussion
it's a great example of show don't tell
and managing to be like historically
accurate in a story because a lot of
people will say like well I can't
include this character because of the
setting or I don't want to include a
character because I don't want it to be
offensive because I'm not going to have
our modern terminology to discuss this
and it's like well treat it like you
would treat any other aspect of the
character and allow them to explain
themselves see oh speaking of this male
characters writing really good
non-binary characters I want to talk
about podcasts because podcasts and web
comics and and web shows like you
stopped writing down web comic examples
is like there's too many of these
because they have such low gatekeeping
standards that's the place that queer
people queer people have been telling
their own stories for like a decade two
decades yeah like that's that's where
our stories have been has been in web
comics for years and with the rise of
podcasting and of fiction podcasting
specifically that's been sort of the new
frontier in queer storytelling so first
I want to talk about my favorite
podcasters ever the McIlroy's and if
anyone here knows me personally
or has listened to any podcast I
shouldn't know you were gonna find a way
to bring them up I should have called
that I'm annoyed with myself that I'm
surprised that you are bringing them up
and that you found a way to do it you
legitimately should have known better
yeah I really friends on Facebook you
know these things yeah so in their
Dungeons & Dragons podcast the adventure
zone another example of having a
non-binary charactering like a fantasy
medieval ask setting you know nan a nan
modern setting one of the characters
that they created was a an elemental
creature by the name of Roswell and
Roswell used they/them pronouns and
Roswell was awesome again the this is an
example of the trope is not the problem
itself it's the pervasiveness of the
trope that's the problem because this is
one of those cases of Roswell is not
human yeah well it's not a single person
Roswell II is a literal object but a
sentient object and as a sentient object
could have a gender but doesn't and
there could have been a lot of pitfalls
that this character fell into but
because they intentionally were like
we're gonna make Roswell a cool
interesting like badass character with
their own like goals and aspirations and
ideals and thoughts it's it's a it's a
good example Roswell is a good character
but still falls into some of these traps
of like well but you know technically
they're not human and yeah they're
sentient and especially in a fantasy
world where you know you have elves and
dwarves and stuff like just because
you're not human doesn't mean you're not
a person like that's that's not a
connotation within the world it's still
sort of a connotation in the real world
so you could probably do better and they
said yeah you know what I think we can
do better so in their current arc that
they are doing which is set in
modern-day West Virginia
hilariously because they're all from
West Virginia it's two of them still
live in West Virginia it's the wild
far-off fantasy literally the next
county over its Pocahontas County which
is like 25 minutes away from where
Justin lives for man there is a
character in that show who is a a
motorcycle riding monster hunter named
Hollis and Hollis is awesome Hollis is
great
Hollis takes no guff Hollis has a thick
accent and Hollis has a baseball bat and
Hollis basically from stranger things of
adventure zone amnesty and they're great
they're great and I love them Steve was
the only good thing about the second
season of that show so you sold that to
me very well that's all you need it
imagine Steve but like with 14 other
like bike gang buddies who all act
really tough but they're all just like
soft West Virginia boys like it's great
it's great the other this is this is the
big like podcast example and I'm
surprised like it's so entrenched like
in my corner of podcasting that I'm
really surprised that I like more people
don't know about it but there is a show
called the penumbra podcast okay and it
is also a a fiction podcast it
originally started off as a Twilight
Zone pastiche where they would do their
own sort of Twilight Zone ask takes on
different genre stories most of them
being sort of horror but what the their
literal first episode was a story called
Juneau steel and the case of the
murderous mask and it was a war pastiche
and that two-part story ended up being
the runaway hit of the podcast by it
like episode 8 everyone was in love with
Juneau they would do two episodes of
Juneau and then
something else he is a non-binary
bisexual depressed detective on Mars
that I love I love that as a final
capper - to end on on Mars
yeah because of course because why not
Juneau steel is as a result the
longest-running character that's been in
that series and thus is the character
who also has the most depth notable
aspects about Juneau steel is that he
does use he/him pronouns but he very
insistently refers to himself as a lady
so he is actually the femme fatale of
the series oh he is the suave lady who
sweeps in in a cloud of smoke and ruins
everyone else's life but he's also the
protagonist which means that then the
people who care about him have to deal
with the fact that they love this
depressed by sexual disaster who is
actively destroying his own life and
hoping that no one notices it's great
it's a wonderful it's a wonderful story
it's super compelling he is bisexual as
I said and has a a male sort of
antagonist lover there they have a
fantastic dynamic and and that very
fraught romance is played out in a very
realistic way I would say a surprisingly
realistic way considering that it is
about noir detectives who solve alien
murders on Mars it is a very grounded
series and a lot of Juno's mental
illness and gender identity and sexual
orientation is treated with a lot of
respect and honesty because the
creator's are themselves we're and in a
lot
cases struggling with their own mental
illnesses and bring that understanding
that compassion into their storytelling
something that they have said
occasionally in commentaries is that
until assumed other like all characters
on Mars are queer until proven otherwise
spoilers they won't be everyone on Mars
is gay or trans or ace or queer or
something there are there are no
Cicero's in space none Hyperion city is
interesting I might need to try and find
time in my life to check this out I'm
not saying that everyone needs to listen
to the penumbra podcast but I honestly
feel like everyone especially if you
yourself are not cisgender or straight
like you should listen to this because
it
it honestly does feel like coming home I
think I have one more Who am I oh my
gosh I can't believe I almost forgot to
talk about Steven universe on an episode
about non-binary representation I didn't
bring this up because I wasn't sure what
to make it because this is kind of an
amalgam character at least that I have
which was stevonnie yes so we're going
to talk about stevonnie because the
creator rebecca sugar a couple of years
ago came out as non-binary herself and
said that a lot of the subtext that
people had been picking up on the show
by this point it was like season 3 2 or
3 something like that and said that yes
all of the subtext that people were
picking up on about how gem fusion was a
representation of relationships and in
specifically of explicitly queer
relationships yes they were right all of
the gems are canonically non-binary
every single one because this is one of
those examples of you know alien biology
that all gems come from a world where
it's just gems there's no sexual
dimorphism so gems are just gems it's
shown that they very much use she/her
pronouns out of convenience because they
do present themselves feminine ly and
appear physically to look like women but
at the end of the day that they are
their rocks like literal rocks the body
is a projection and the body is
essentially for them like clothing
presentation that they can look however
they like so this is just how a gem is
supposed to look and you know whether it
be a ruby or a sapphire or a pearl or
whatever like that's just what you look
like because that's what you're expected
to look like so in one sense gems only
have one gender and in essence each
individual type of gem is its own sort
of gender with its own expectations its
own rules and within that case gems of
different types are not supposed to mix
that's not that's not considered
socially acceptable on their world so
every single fusion is thus a queer
relationship it is it is a relationship
between women but also between
non-binary characters but also groups
that are not supposed to be involved in
that sort of like emotionally important
relationships with one another and like
explicitly romantic relationships with
one another but all of that could be
sort of hand waved away as like well
that's word of god or it's a
technicality or well they don't have any
gender so it doesn't matter
stevonnie is actually a fusion like
other gem fusions except it's a fusion
with a human
so for stevonnie they are the
representation of the relationship with
between two major characters Steven and
Connie you know the protagonist and his
primary love interest and
as a result their fusion uses they/them
pronouns whereas other fusions use sheep
because it's she-she fusion she yeah so
that means that all of stephen's fusions
with any other gem also uses de them
pronouns and it's it's a cool function
of the show because it allows you to
talk about relationships by embodying
the relationship in a single character
and then any sort of character conflict
that that character has is then an
example of the relationship conflict and
that could be like within the
relationship or the way that it's
perceived by others some people I have I
have heard are not totally happy with
stevonnie as a representation of a
non-binary character but like I am
pleased as punch
I love stevonnie I think they're like
one of the coolest non-binary characters
ever like in a lot of ways they appear
to be more feminine coded which as I
said like earlier is pretty rare most
people are like oh you're a non-binary
person that means you need to look at
drogyn s which means you need to look
masculine and you know stevonnie has
like big hair and big hips and like
that's cool that's just what Stefani
looks like that's what that's what they
look like and they're a day and that's
valid now I have one of this totally
random but I want to toss this in at the
end because I thought this was cute now
I only have the first volume of this
comic I guess it was originally a
webcomic so Phoebe and her unicorn but I
don't I don't I don't actually know it
is about this it's very it's it's very
cute and it's ridiculous it's kind of
high energy it's it's it's a fun little
thing so there is a there is a unicorn
character introduced I guess later on
called Infernus unicorn of death I love
them already
who is non-binary and uses nay pronoun
okay
okay see that's fun that's how you do I
know where else to put that I just
wanted to get that in there
yeah I think that's that's about a good
place to wrap up I cannot thank you
enough not only for talking with me but
for doing a hell of a lot more language
like this this is an episode where I
actually did some level of research and
it's still just mainly me sitting back
going you know what you're talking about
I'll just I'll just be here well you
know what I was glad to be your expert
witness I'm very happy to have you so
what what do you feel like plugging at
the very end I think the big one that
I'm actually gonna plug right now is
actually darkness to light because it is
the it's kind of my baby so I started
doing one podcast Network series with my
dad which is relatively geeky and you
know that's that's all fun and well and
good but over the last year I've been
devoting a lot more of my time to our
little side project which is called
dorkiness to light that is darkness for
the no not with an a and it is all about
religion and spirituality and pop
culture and I was raised Christian he is
still practicing Christian and we talk
about stuff so often from a Christian
point of view but also from a pagan or a
Jewish or or any sort of any sort of
sort of spiritual tendency the person
might lean towards that they can find in
pop culture and we want to talk about
that sort of stuff and I really I really
like doing that I've been meeting a lot
of like really cool people on the
internet and getting lots of cool
feedback about that sort of stuff so
that's the big thing that I've been
spending a lot of my time on that I
really enjoy doing the most honestly
kind of warm
art that that was the one you decided to
plunge harder be good speaking of
someone who is not raised in any
religion and doesn't practice I still
love that thank you I love that podcast
I think it's a well and this is not
gonna be a huge surprise probably for
anyone who's watching this but you have
written into that show and talked about
your yeah just a little every now and
then third member of the team over here
in the corner but like like that's the
sort of thing that we love we love
having people's like personal
experiences and talking about like this
was meaningful to me on like what could
be a considered a religious level but I
don't practice any sort of religion cool
awesome
like the it's a big thing that I believe
in as a non-binary person breaking down
breaking down walls I actually want to
plug a thing that I'm not on but one of
my like fellow people in this very very
very very very very very small corner of
the internet that is podcasting about
religion from a queer perspective which
is a show called blessed be the binary
breakers which is by a non-binary
seminarian highly recommended Avery is
super cool and they're like a really
cool person who kind of runs in my
general circles and I want to want to
plug their stuff so if you want to hear
more stuff about like non-binary people
and non-binary people living our lives
that would be probably a really good
place to start
all right that sounds awesome very cool
I think there's five or six episodes
that are up now so something something
like that but it's the show is still in
its sort of infancy so like whenever I
have a chance to sort of like get a
little a couple a couple numbers boosts
I think that every would probably really
appreciate it they just graduated so
like I don't know if they've been
checking their download numbers recently
but I'm like what would be a nice
graduation present have an extra 35
downloads or some
every little helps and thank you again
so much for for taking the time and and
for doing this I'm really glad you said
yes it was a pleasure this is great we
need to talk more often um oh my god in
general like are you free probably
probably wrapped for now unfortunately
yeah those great another huge thanks to
em for joining me on this thank you for
sticking all the way through it I hope
you will check out some of their things
some of the things that got recommended
I know I now have a list of stuff to
check out you can tell how long ago this
dot was shot because of how much the
color is faded in my hair versus what
you just saw in the video but in any
case I hope you enjoy it whatever your
thoughts aren't anything we talked about
any of the examples cited any ones that
you want to toss into the mix drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it other stuff to do them there as
well like subscribe both of which are
helpful and you can keep track of the
stuff that gets put out there you can
support me on patreon which helps me pay
my bills and make the channel bigger and
better other links down there besides
for my social medias and a link to the
book I wrote on being gender-fluid etc
etc check those out click on links or
don't you don't have to because at the
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meanings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]